dr fauci is back in talking about the
new coveted variant and the possibility
it would bring back restrictions
fauci says we need to be flexible
i don't see us going back into any more
really very restrict kinds of
restrictions but you always have to have
the flexibility if we do see
a significant surge particularly one
that might result in increased
hospitalizations we have to be prepared
to pivot and perhaps reinstitute some of
those restrictions
and as fouchy floats the idea of
possible new restrictions he's also
flooding the idea of retirement
republican senator ron johnson telling
fox and friends weekend it's about time
he goes
it's well past time when he should have
retired
um
you know i don't see how anybody can
take a look at our response to kovid
965 000 americans dead over six million
people worldwide the human told the
economic devastation from these
widespread shutdowns what we have done
to our children put them in a state of
fear is a travesty
the anthony fauci led this miserable
failure of a response he should be held
accountable
okay so before we get to talking about
fauci riding off to the sunset uh tammy
i have to ask you uh you're a very wise
uh shrewd observer of
political
things
is there anybody left who is eager for
new mandates or going back to
all of the things that we've endured for
the past two years well there are as a
matter of fact the new york times did a
story and a poll they instituted their
own poll they found that the very
liberal
versus the liberal moderates and
conservatives
remained in fear they wanted the
mandates more so than every other
category now perhaps dr fauci is a very
liberal but this talks to you about it
speaks to the the the nature of what's
happened to the liberal base the
ultimate liberals the far left the
progressives
that this is how they think the reality
is this is more fear-mongering he says
this as we're coming out of this we do
know that again it was a failure what he
implemented it has been the one success
story has been the vaccines brought to
us by president trump and natural
immunity because of the amount of people
who have been infected uh over like i
think it's 80 percent of americans have
had some shot or dynamic and so this is
why we're looking at a v this is this is
not march of 2020 my goodness and this
is a man who is speaking as though
nothing has happened in the meantime
everything is different the world is
different natural immunity the vaccines
everything we've learned not masks we
know the world health organization the
world europe italy know that this is not
right and this is just more
fear-mongering from a man who does need
to leave the scene and of course as you
know uh no true self-respecting liberal
would actually uh want to wiggle under
the thumb of an authoritarian like
anthony fauci in the first place but
that's for another time um alicia i want
you to listen to this uh this comment
from dr fauci talk about retirement
are we approaching the point where we
are past the pandemic phase and you'll
go get some rest
i'm not so sure george i want to make
sure we're really out of this before i
really seriously consider doing anything
different we're still in this we have a
way to go
so alicia
it's terrible uh alicia is it time for
for him to possibly retire it might be
and it's going to be up to him i do
think that this serves
the last two years have really served as
a warning to any future health care
leaders in this country that if you're
not careful against a political backdrop
and you're a doctor and you appear to be
taking a side there will be people who
will listen even closer if they agree
with your side but we have millions of
other people in this country who felt
ignored by the side that they thought dr
fauci was taking that can be dangerous
there were careers during this pandemic
that were built and destroyed all while
millions of people around the globe died
so whether or not he retires i don't
know that it exactly changes the game i
think a lot of mistakes were made and
there are a lot of lessons to be learned
so reasonable absolute reasonable woman
here yeah absolutely but you know i
don't have a whole lot of faith that
anybody's uh in government anyway is
learning those lessons but it is uh
alarming the degree to which uh because
this stuff got so politicized the degree
to which they destroyed not only their
own credibility but the credibility of
uh their their successors to deal with
another problem like this um i don't i
don't think i'll ever believe uh this
you know a government bureaucrat when it
comes to to health care joey i mean if
you you know and and and if you had a p
if your kid's pediatrician was had been
had gotten as many things wrong
taking care of your child as dr fauci
has in this pandemic you would have
fired him two years ago listen well they
went from 15 days to slow to spread to
lock everything down because you can't
afford to catch this virus
they lost me like i'm not that stupid i
listen i know the difference between the
two things and when you try to slide
your hands
you lose me imagine having the hubris
yeah to think that you can't that if you
retire a country of 330 million
americans aren't smart enough to figure
it out for themselves
i mean think how the people that work
for him feel uh that might have a
different opinion and are absolutely
brilliant in their own right uh this guy
for for all whatever his intentions are
and i will not try to assign him
he has to understand that the country's
going to move on with or without him and
uh and and with him may look like him
playing some golf with president trump
maybe or something
it's truly a remarkable the the vast
disconnect uh and i think that's been a
major problem with the entire
government's uh response to all of it
but uh great stuff guys uh hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else